[Music]
laughlin can go wherever indian really
has this aura so tactically all of India
it was the first possible payments
[Music]
lifeline Express has been around for
about 25 years there has been over a
million patient encounters since
obstructed and over a hundred thousand
surgeries I am dr. Luke Gorzelanny
I'm a neurologist the mission has been
to take medical services to the people
wherever deprivation disability and
poverty coexisted rural India doesn't
really have much of healthcare
facilities lifeline Express has
operation theaters and area for
consolidations and minor procedures and
coaches fault
office space and so on the lifeline
Express focuses on cataract surgeries
issues like cleft lip and cleft palate
epilepsy breast and oral cancer and
family planning
before the project happens there is
publicity in the markets in the town
then there are posters put up there are
patients that are coming around from the
surrounding areas there are some days
when I have seen close to 100 patients
already at every project we get at least
about 25 to 30 volunteer doctors and
then there are about 25 to 30 doctors
who come in from the location itself our
patients are grateful for what we do for
them and I see it as a way to give back
I think empathy letting them know that
whatever is possible is being done and
more importantly curing them out it all
is part of the healing process
[Music]
by using as a washout so traditionally
what is real on yang what is socialized
don't we the genie love isn't a who I
found you dad isn't home move to the
other don't belong the penitent Allah
curtain two
sorry so geometers Jung Poong to be the
judge we hug too
[Music]
what LD - honk - and spatula today I
hold on change him examine what Anthony
once you go to disagree shouting you go
three years sanction when I come to a
poker game - he goes so that turn so
Buffy he goes idea why it should be
proven well food I mean they go chewy
Duncan said IOU JD mountains and Toyama
pharmacy we go through year we really go
put in the samples again you may go
Buddhist sharpest again Yoshi will have
found in to give me some Japan to let
him down you call it a nubian kiddin
pardon woman yoohoo news channel Bank
overwatch Jesus pardon Juden Juden away
Sonny comic I see you in your life my
banishment anemia so the table where I
go to so you notice anything new
simply a bundle derivative are the koala
guna almost younger net enhancer you
downtown to Zulu
[Music]
you
what kind of England Guggenheim Jenny
yes return to comment on camera were a
Hungarian going Camille uber to Johnny
sutrayana Haddad go sonic Khosla sorry
balcony come to a session Laura - Aloha
see when this on aluminum granted if she
wanna come - I miss you need Jinsu mas
[Music]
[Music]
Ithaca capacity buffer on to access
comprar for passive world
AHA traditionally Karnataka's around if
Abdul Divya
zapping and of Braganza SWAT to
determine the man Terry masala and
Patrick with an and transport RC III o
knots but for the public to see a heat
capacity paren transform ya da cunha
give up will swap even at a Makita
priori past Ryan and together I trap
tomandamanda bubble congenial or teeth
tongue capacity under a fan territory
fully mouth prospect where you put two
together if you wanna run young couple
to ANBU Susie and silky Tom who police
a/c [ __ ] command Amalia still Anya
deploy across officer Kadam of the
decisive identification of gaya number
that the truth - thump a plan to put
money on iris capacity at man kita motor
integrity missing the exacto single sip
on to the market again satellite even
but we'll check in the war zero dad
blow it defied approach Allah Rakha
it's a visa program a career depression
fujitani appropriate strategies and
enter Breaka Kumano Kodo school annuity
katana Bromberg and again in finances
our image the colonial warriors
awakening
[Music]
we're a big group of strong women that
takes risks riding motorcycles all the
time in the city which takes a set of
steel ovaries in my opinion but we want
to help babies he says no to babies the
club delivers process and pasteurized
donor breast milk to mothers and babies
in need both to Nick use in hospitals
and to private homes we focus our
service on the women's health issues so
this is complete fit for what we try to
do as a club the call for milk can come
at any time you can be anywhere we pull
up to the dock at the New York milk Bank
Julie brings out the milk that's been
prepackaged in freezer bags and boxes we
strap it down to the motorcycles this is
it the way when we opened up the milk
bank
I was actually stuck in traffic with my
husband and saw a motorcycle rider
illegally driving up the center lane and
I thought why can't we use motorcyclists
to deliver milk in and out of New York
we collected from women that have an
excess amount of milk we process it test
it and distribute it to hospitals for
premature infants and to the community
at large Marla was born four months
early
I brought Marlo home after a hundred and
sixty-one days in the NICU I stopped
producing breast milk and all of Marlo's
doctors required Marlo to continue on
breast milk because putting her on
formula would gravely endanger her life
I had to find a way to be able to give
my daughter breast milk and I found
donor milk since then we've been getting
deliveries from the milk bank we get
delivery once a month it's three hundred
and thirty bottles of three ounces
the sound of the motorcycles is the
sound of hope they're bringing life
liquid life or a small baby ooh I don't
know every time I give Marlo a bottle I
start to think about what's in there
it's not just one woman's work I know
the hard work energy labor love
dedication and sacrifice that goes into
every ounce we don't waste a drop around
here it's um
priceless Indian weddings are really
huge on an average Indian wedding that
is always 100 250 plates of excess food
that's where we are coming in collecting
it and distribute it to the needy
[Music]
Indians produce 10.8 percent of the
world's food but he have more and more
people hungry in India sleeping without
food
I am padmanaban gopalan I started non
profit no food waste in 2014 no food
waste is an excess food recovery Network
that collects untouched surplus food
from various events and parties and
delivers to the hunger spots across the
city like orphanages slums old-age homes
dump yachts and government hospitals as
of today we have collected and
distributed about two hundred and
eighty-five thousand plates of food to
the needy people we launched a helpline
number that is explained in across the
marriage halls and the hotels when there
is excess food people called to the cell
plane number then we organized pickups
with our vehicles and this food is being
served within four house of collection
no food waste initially started in
Coimbatore and now we are in almost ten
cities it is only because of volunteers
the number of calls is very huge right
now we are able to cover only thirty to
thirty-five percent of the calls would
be received to arrange logistics and
infrastructure to recover food from all
this marriage faults becomes a challenge
people are generally aware of food waste
problem in their marriages and events
but they were not aware of what to do
with this excess food there is no words
to explain the pain of hunger the
success of no food waste is to see a
food waste free India and a hunger free
India when we collected all this food
and delivered to the slums in different
areas it will feel happy about it and
seeing smiles on those people makes us
really happy to continue this job feed
people not landfills
[Music]